hey how are you what's your name Valeria
Valeria
so I tried putting off the podcast
listening to it for the longest time
because I could not wait for episodes
like every week to come out oh you let
them Bank up so I was like
sorry earlier this year I actually kind
of caught up fully and I noticed sona's
improv skills completely like
100 improved no they have not don't
apply that's not true but okay thank you
very much thing is you're always good
but thing that I've noticed about Sona
that's so rare is she's always 100
herself no matter what we do we've done
shows like this at you know that we're
going to do them in the Beacon Theater
in New York we've done them here in Los
Angeles yeah uh at The Wiltern just
throw us in front of thousands and
there's like thousands of people and I'm
used to that but Sona will go and she'll
do that and people were screaming Sona
Sona Sona and she's like all right and
then she'll walk off stage and be like
I'm hungry
I'm always well I'll see you later and
she'll act like nothing happened and you
know there's so many people that would
be saying oh this is my chance to be an
influencer and uh and pretend I have a
jet
um no one really has a job they all hold
the toilet seat up really closely and
take a selfie
and
some sparkling apple cider they're
holding up but yeah you don't you're
always yourself which is a great quality
it's nice to have nothing to lose
because I'm on Conan O'Brien needs a
friend and if I'm bad it just reflects
on you so I think that it shows that I
made a bad joke it's just that you you
had poor judgment putting me on so it
just it's very freeing and liberating to
just know I can say and do whatever I
want and it just makes you look bad
you're fired